ما الفرق بين الجوله الاولى والجوله
الثانيه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
من حيث الخطاب السياسي لكل مرشح لنا في
الجوله الاولى
ركز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على
انجازاته ولا اكثر من 20 عاما تحدث عن
الانفاق على الجسور على المستشفيات عن
السفن الحربيه عن المسيرات عن المحطه
النوويه وغيرها
اختار لنفسه شعار الرجل المناسب
منع كمال
على الوضع الاقتصادي
على التاخير وعلى انه رئيس لكل فئات
المجتمع على حقوق المراه على حقوق
المطهدين على حقوق الاكراد وان لم يقل ذلك
علانيه وشعاره
كان بان الربيع في الجوله الثانيه استمر
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان على النفس الخطاب
السياسي
فتغير الخطاب السياسي وتوجه بشكل كبير الى
التصعيد امام اللاجئين بشكل خاص التصعيد
لوجه السوريين الشعارات التي لا نراها
الان ولكنها موجوده في الشوارع هيا
السوريون سيعودون
هذا هو الذي يركز عليه في خطابه السياسي
هذه المره